I'm a beautiful fan so let me tell you
something I've been getting a lot of the
ends of people or needs and me affection
over we came up with a way that we are
going to give out $1,000 an hour for the
next 42 days yep that's right you know
sometimes you give to charity and you
wonder like hmm is there really going to
the people well we're gonna make sure
it's going to the people Carty be
helping to support those struggling to
make ends meet during the corona virus
pandemic the 27 year old rapper and
fashion Nova announced on Wednesday that
they will give $1,000 an hour until May
20th which will total up to around 1
million dollars in financial assistance
fashion Nova will choose 24 winners each
day to receive a $1,000 check which they
can use towards purchasing food or
paying their bills those looking for
relief should head over to fashion Nova
comm slash cares to apply make sure your
Instagram is open because I'm gonna make
sure that you really do need it that's
right the Grammy winner revealed that
she will be personally vetting those who
apply to make sure that the money goes
into the right hands in a press release
the CEO of fashion Nova Richard Sagan
said quote fashion Nova cares with cardi
B will provide people with necessary
relief to help them get through the
crisis as a community-driven brand we
are inspired by the kindness and
generosity of others and we wanted to do
our part to help those in need we love
you guys and we are so thankful that you
guys have been supporting us for the for
so long it's not for us to support you
guys back and I love you and don't be
shy sometimes you got a mother who can
ask for help
Lidl me last week multiple outlets
reported cardi B donated to New York
City health care workers on the front
lines providing 20,000 bottles of a
plant-based vegan meal supplement drink
to hospitals around the city she's also
been very vocal about her concerns
surrounding koba 19 on social media if
you're positive for the corner berries
but you don't have a crazy fever but you
have a cold and you're sending people
home I don't know what do they think
they're sending people home to now
everybody has the luxury to go into his
bedroom and to go in a big-ass house and
just stay away from people people live
in small
as apartments a lot of people live in
smallest apartment with multiple people
so that if you send me home and I have
to call up iris I'm most likely gonna
give it to now my spouse my kids anybody
that's around me cardi is doing what she
can to keep her fans aware at this time
advising them to drink plenty of hot
liquids and of course avoid foods that
will give you mucus I've gone down from
Wuhan China now and let me tell you
something I don't go front and then I
you my biggest joke keke keke keke like
I was thinking right but that's it right
there just because you think you are
Mewtwo I guess well your pocket ain't a
lot for mother China so if you wonder
where your squeeze or your fashion /
mother packages have arrived guess what
Korona berry
[Music]